the beautiful lady that i would like to
choose
is
big man 10 years castillo first aka the
main event aka the sniper breath shout
out to your baby mama now big man senior
we live in a world full of clout chasers
bro and i'm sick of it why can't a real
g let me find some real love grab you
could get nosebleeds when you get the
wrong naan bread how this is gonna work
is i'm actually gonna slap money in
front of these galbrai 1000 for my
eternal love and i'm going to try and
find out if they get them here for the
money and clown or they're there for
real love big man ting this is cloud
chasers brad
big man senior breve has had some
nice dates for five beautiful women in
that rev so
i'm gonna have to weed through them you
know to make a decision and it's a hard
decision reps when i'm looking at the
roster and that they all fit the
criteria you get me man likes all
different flavors in that you look nice
thank you everything's just working
right now that outfit everything is it
yeah yeah the baby hair's in that i see
you i'm not gonna lie angel seemed like
she was full of a bag of [ __ ] brother
i'm not gonna lie i look like you're
chatting
bear [ __ ] but
she can kind of get away with that you
get me but not with me though about so i
don't know i don't know
uh troll from hastings actually which is
three hours away
is that near birmingham
but
to look at she's beautiful you get me
that's like a 10 out of 10 right there i
look good like i know you want me
like it's cool to say i don't eat [ __ ]
like you think they're lying yeah of
course a lot of them are lying i like
esther i liked her honesty you get me i
like that i like she was honest so is
that on your checklist like you must eat
the eat the party in there yeah 100 what
i liked about esther yeah besides the
beautiful melanin and that you get me
shout out to the queens i like the fact
that she didn't really give up she was
blunt what would you eat his body
sure that's a no for you
i could the main thing that kind of put
me off about i'm not gonna lie about
this yet was when she said she baited
out that brother she was chatting to i
don't know about
them federally
policy of business there brother i don't
know about that do you like black guys
do i like black guys love black guys
yeah what are you what do you think
about black people now i'm just joking
i'm taking them
the date with cat was amazing you get me
she's got beautiful eyes yeah and the
hair is nice you get me in her vibes
nice like i could tell she's a good girl
you get me yeah now i feel you can't be
giving up the non-breading night to
everybody you get me nobody deserves the
naan bread you get me
the maddest thing is here she seemed
proper since seeing that but you can
never tell what a girl in values you
just never know
a bit too cute for me and all that i
like them a bit dangerous but she was
nice the date with the nova was blessed
like she's mad fiery in that i like that
you seem like you got like some bossy
aura
i'm a dangerous woman they say dangerous
what kind of danger are we talking about
get me i could tell she don't take no
[ __ ] so there's something about that
that does it for me an accent
[ __ ] but she seems real like she said
that man was in a madness so she went
lying about that so i gave her a little
bit of trust there big man saying the
day of imogen that was blessed i like
her that's my type of girl right there
she seemed very genuine but like i said
you never know yeah so you've got to let
me know what you want what you're
looking for so what are you looking for
i'm looking for love i'm looking for you
to be see alana you've got bars she got
body you get me legs
get me a tall thing breath man felt like
jacking a beanstalk on that but it's mad
i don't know man she just gave me signs
like like [ __ ] rap i'm not gonna lie
this was kind of dope
yo
big man ting
it's nice to see you ladies again you're
all looking beautiful i'm not gonna lie
wow
yeah i'm blown away right now i'm not
even gonna lie to you yeah
you don't already know why i'm doing
this thing i've been trying to find love
so this thing as you lot know is called
love or clout clout chasers yeah so i'm
gonna be doing
i'm gonna be telling you a lot to step
forward and i'm going to be eliminating
one by one
[Music]
so this is what we find out
this is where we find out if it's love
or clown
the decision is going to be hard you get
me because all of them they're all
beautiful they're all different you get
me they're all giving me different
different vibes in that so it's a
difficult decision to make but i'm not
gonna lie i've got my one two favorites
you get me
now big man sing i've been on dates of
all of you and each and every one of you
is different and unique in your own way
i love it
imogen you came with the vibes beautiful
personality thank you yeah you came with
the you came with the feistiness and i
love it do you remember my name
the nova oh big
[Laughter]
amazing energy beautiful eyes as well oh
thank you that star you came with the
real one i love it yeah it came with a
real i love it and it was honest and
open and you're beautiful yeah angel he
was real as well came with the vibes and
he didn't hold back
yeah
i thought he was going to be a bit timid
but you came with it
big man yeah don't be smiling hard now
though
it could change at any moment so what
i'm gonna be doing i'm gonna be telling
one of you ladies to step forward and be
eliminated
don't go home and cry
[Laughter]
life goes on
for me anyway again so how are you
feeling right now you're making me
nervous i know it's because you've been
talking here
so big man sing the first beautiful lady
that i'd like to eliminate first you
gotta step forward
so
step forward
cat
oh okay
it's fine don't worry i'll be real for
you yeah okay you're beautiful
everything's put together nicely so i
see right through you i'm not gonna lie
you see through me right for you tell
that you're on some [ __ ] and you're
trying to trick me okay it's way too
nice i'm just a nice person way too nice
and i don't believe it you don't believe
it there's a little cloud chasing going
on oh really
also your real one but at the same time
we're both struggling in some ways and i
feel like
you're on a hustle
and i feel like at some point one of us
is going to have to sell our bum to pay
the rent
well you know you should get an only fan
so for that reason okay i've got
eliminate you oh well can we have a hug
no bro you can't get out no not hard
okay that's how it's gonna be okay
nice to meet you though anyway good luck
with your journey okay
oh my god
see that guys big mansion i hate to see
her go but i'd love to see her leave
nice
so
the next beautiful lady that i'd like to
eliminate
step forward
esther
okay
now
the date was banging you look beautiful
everything's nice to smile everything
yeah but
you said something a bit mad
yeah you said which one
you baited up some man he was chatting
too because he was chance of a girl and
i can't do that that's some policeman
business
i don't want to end up on the block
and also you said something even more
mad what did i say you said you eat the
barty
yeah you said you eat bambam and i'm not
gonna lie
you can't be kissing
i said i would eat it but you were
piping up saying that you do madness so
it looks man can't be doing that
so for that reason
you've got a goal okay
okay oh it's been cute it's been cute i
don't know it has all right see you
later big mention
now we're down to three
ladies how are you feeling feeling good
the palm sweaty yes actually my arms are
sweating good that's how you make the
mandem feel when you go on dates
nervous now
the next girl i'd like to eliminate
is
step forward
[Music]
imogen you're really killing me right
now now i'm not gonna lie
he was numero uno yeah you're beautiful
you're tall your personality is 10 out
of 10. but it's too perfect there's
something going on right there
100. i feel like there's a man out there
somewhere and if he finds out where to
give her he's going to track me down and
i'm going to end up missing like
madeleine mccain
and that's a long time
wow okay otherwise it would have been a
done though
so for that reason i'm gonna have to
eliminate it and it hurts me back but
i'm just saying okay let me give you a
hug
i appreciate it anyway i'll take that
done
good luck
how can you do that you're down to the
two babes and you're looking at the
other one big mountain all right down to
the final two you ladies have made it
this far but
i'm gonna take the choice away from me
and i want you a lot to do something for
me here you ladies need to convince me
as to why i need to pick you why should
i pick you for the final
30 seconds
ready
okay so i'm intelligent i'm funny i'm
sweet
elegant and a baddie all in one
and i cook very well too
and i mean you can probably help me
finish my sleeves
so i don't know we've got plenty to talk
about
i was like my hands are shaking but um
yeah i mean i'm funny i can cook too and
study as a chef i
i do modeling and stuff i feel like i'm
nice enough to be with someone and
actually create something for the future
and you know i mean i'm just yeah i'm
just me
i don't know
i know i like that i like that this has
been difficult
i'm not gonna lie it's been very very
difficult you two have made it to the
final i'm gonna start with you angel
yeah i'm not gonna lie at first i
thought it was gonna be mad dry on some
jacob's crackers ting
i thought you weren't gonna be lit but
you was lit and you was real and in a
bit that sold me i asked you if a girl
got rooted in a rave what did you do and
you said you'd bust them up so you got
them hands
i rate that done now now the nelva not
gonna lie you came with the energy the
fire and i like it and you sound like
you can hold it down you're coming from
a real place
and the accent is ten out of ten i'm not
gonna lie it does things to me i can't
say on this camera right now because i
will get arrested and it's mad
yeah so
the beautiful lady that i would like to
choose
is
but wait
we're not finished yet
we still got to make a decision
yeah and this is the final bit is the
most important bit
get me you got to choose
love
or money
cheers to the second date
cheers done now big mention how'd you
feel
i feel
gassed actually you feel good the
competition was fierce there's a lot of
beautiful girls they
were really nice
i don't know it's a privilege thank you
no worries why did you think i picked
you
i think you liked the challenge overall
i could tell that obviously my energy
seems to be a bit different to maybe
what you're accustomed to you know i'm
not playing i don't tell you too much
but i tell you enough so i'm not gonna
lie here this is what i liked about
energy he was feisty he was real
and i like the fact that you pulled me
up on the [ __ ] so i like that yeah
that's why i had to choose you thank you
but
we're not out of it yet yeah like i said
i'm still putting myself on the line get
me don't need to make me look like an
idiot on big big youtube in that so
you've got a decision to make you get me
we both got a decision to make
so as you already know the show is
called clout chasers love all money so
we both got to make a decision right now
yeah don't make me look like an idiot in
front of my people then
i'll try my best so big man sing let me
explain how this works yeah
so if i pick love
and you pick love yeah
we go off into the sunset white picket
fence the utes and the dog we have some
pretty black babies yeah that's what
happens with nice hair big man thing
okay yeah and we both share the money
yeah
okay now
if i pick
money
and you pick money you ain't getting
cool back
get me you're going back that's the
universal credit team i'm not gonna lie
if i pick love
and you pick money
you're just killed off my whole flow the
whole reason i'm trying to find love
everything everything's gone then that
means you get all the p's you get
everything get me get all of that yeah
and i don't get cool ain't getting no
love i ain't getting no p's and i'm back
to square one breath i've got slang
willy all throughout the streets all
throughout the community and get me
gonna have to set up for only fans it's
a big responsibility all the people that
was seeing this it's a main event big
man thing yeah
if i choose money and you choose love
that means you were sincere and i just
didn't believe you you get me that means
all these little past things i just
don't trust the girl them okay yeah
big menting and i lose that on the love
so it's bad for me you're down on real
love
and you lose out on the money
i understand are you ready are you ready
i'm ready
so now what should i choose should i
trust you should i really trust you it's
up to you i told you what i needed to
tell you if you believe you believe if
you don't you don't but i'm telling you
right now i'm a sagittarius we lead with
truth
it's giving scammer vibes i'm not gonna
lie it's giving hush puppy right now i'm
not gonna lie let me switch these things
around switch it million times what do
you think do you think i need money or
do you think i need love i don't know
what your life's saying right now i
don't know things can be hard look at me
what do you think my life's saying
pigmenting who knows we're gonna find
out though cool are you ready i'm ready
wait wait before i make my decision i
wanna ask you a question are you ready
for love i'm ready for love are you
ready to take care of a woman like me
pigmenting of course can you handle a
woman like me
are you sure don't know are you jealous
i'm a jealous person nah brother but
don't make me jealous
i won't make you but you might get
jealous on your own but anyway are you
ready mm-hmm okay let me pick
take off the shades you ready look into
your eyes
[Music]
i'm sorry nah
it's not looking good bro you call me a
scammer what do you think i would do big
man thing
see that's why you can't trust garbage
this is why mandem
it's back to the community rev ask me
why i did it
why did you do it
so
as much as you are a lovely person
i have my standards i feel like you
never asked me exactly what i needed and
what i wanted for my men
so
you know the power is in the woman's
hand i just need to teach you that today
matting
and that's why i should have picked
angel brev
no word of a liar knew it i knew it
maybe maybe
but it's a lesson then you know a
beautiful woman will tell you make sure
you pay attention to your woman
make sure that you care about what she
wants so you can know whether or not you
are what she wants that's all i've got
to tell you baby big mansion shout out
to mother teresa and that big man
singing let that be a lesson to the man
them don't trust girl no way don't trust
them don't trust none of them
yeah because this what's going to happen
bab that pressure and pain brother it's
not normal digital platforms rev big
mention
i'll put some money towards it for
promotion that's right man
i don't know bob
you